Justin Timberlake: this guy, he really broke out as a solo artist.
Do you ever sit back and think, "You know, anyone of us could have done that."...
...or is it that he was just a special guy...
...that he was able to go so far as a solo artist.
I think that was his honest-to-God destiny.
I really do, I think being part of a group was a great stepping stone for him...
...but I think somewhere in the cards, he was destined to be on his own...
...and to have as much success that he has...
...because he honestly deserves it, he's an amazing artist.
I think with us, if any of us would have had equal or comparable success just like him,...
...I still think we'd still be doing this as well.
Right.
I think that's just the kind of bond that we have.
Everybody gets along.
Yeah, I mean we've all gone out there and kind of got our feet wet.
I mean, obviously none of us have had that type of solo success...
...but we have had success as solo artists here and there.
And yet, this is what's most important to us.
I always say Backstreet Boys are larger than the sum of their parts.
Yeah.
Because all five of us together are obviously larger than one individual.
Larger than life.